la primera visita de un líder extranjero
al Brasil liderado nuevamente por la
izquierda el canciller Alemán Olaf
scholes visitó la capital del país
suramericano y se reunió con su
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva un
encuentro en el que shortles celebró la
vuelta de Brasil a la escena
internacional estuvo muy turístico
estoy muy feliz estamos muy contentos de
que Brasil haya regresado al escenario
mundial y también a la integración de la
región latinoamericana nos hicieron
mucha falta Lula vemos sus grandes
planes y tenemos grandes expectativas
por nuestra futura cooperación
uno de los grandes temas en la agenda la
protección de la selva amazónica
Alemania anunció La donación de unos 38
millones de dólares para fortalecer su
conservación y el trabajo conjunto hacia
la generación de energías limpias
la guerra en Ucrania se hizo paso en la
conversación yo les invito a los países
de la región a unirse para condenar las
acciones rusas y evitó mencionar el
envío de armas alemanas a Ucrania Lula
por su parte hizo un llamado a la paz y
enfatizó en la importancia del rol chino
para resolver el conflicto
si voy a China en marzo como estaba
previsto ese es un tema del que quiero
hablar con el presidente
es hora de que china se involucre y
trate de ayudar a encontrar la paz entre
Rusia y Ucrania
después de haber visitado Argentina y
chile en la última etapa de su gira
latinoamericana el canciller Alemán se
va de Brasil con el pedido de su nuevo
presidente de reformular El acuerdo
comercial alcanzado entre mercosur y la
Unión Europea En 2019 clave según el
izquierdista para la futura colaboración
entre América Latina y Europa